[Music]
like looking at myself in a mirror okay
this is definitely the creepiest thing
I've ever done
a mirror that doesn't talk back you
ready evil twin yes this is my real face
or is it okay no this is a mission
impossible but this is the new iPhone 10
and its new facial recognition is on par
with some recent science fiction but how
well does it work and can you fool it to
find out I run it through a series of
everyday and not so everyday tests
including photos masks twins and even
triplets test one everyday use after you
register your face you just have to
glance in the direction of your phone to
unlock it you know it's unlocked when
you see the small padlock open on the
lock screen then you swipe up and you're
in it takes less than a second in most
instances but you do have to look at it
or glance down this doesn't work face ID
still recognize me when I put on glasses
including sunglasses and a hat but not
an awesome mustache now working probably
because it didn't watch me grow it over
time in my tests it also worked with
different skin colors and tones it also
works in the dark okay someone turn the
lights back on test two photos photos
can trick more primitive facial
recognition systems like the Galaxy s8
but on the iPhone 10 cutouts on my face
didn't work no matter how natural I
tried to make them look nope this didn't
work either test three masks but a mask
a real theatrical mask has depth and
detail that a flat image just doesn't an
Apple sophisticated system uses two
cameras and projected infrared dots to
measure the depth of your face so
naturally I had a silicone mask made of
my face like one does
I headed to complete sculptor a New York
City store that helps artists learn to
make prosthetics and masks mark and Sara
applied a lot of goop to my face to make
a silicon mold and after 20 minutes they
had what they needed then three days
later I returned with my very brave
colleague Denise I applied some makeup
to my mask and Mark fit the mask to
Denise's face I don't know what I'm
looking at I think it's kind of like me
it definitely has the same shape and
contours as my face hold that up face ID
was more explicit it did not think it
looked like me I'm gonna truth though
locked hmm yep unlock for me test for
twins and triplets but even a piece of
rubber artistry as fine as this has
nothing on actual DNA or DNA times three
brothers and triplets according to Apple
the chances that a random person could
look at your iPhone 10 and unlock it
with their face is one in a million
so while your roommate can't break in
the chances are a lot greater that your
womb mate can narrow March 26 pam March
26 and these three adorable guys proved
that first I asked Declan to register
his face with the iPhone okay and then I
asked Cormac and Kevin to come back try
with you now yes the kids were able to
get into the phone for turtle twins or
siblings that really look like aren't as
likely Pam and her twin marrow weren't
able to unlock the other's phone nothing
so what have we learned here face ID is
secure reliable and easy to use but if
you try to clone yourself you're asking
for trouble see you in your nightmares
oh yeah yeah